yes well okay maybe he might be a bit
frustrated but as soon as he sits as
soon as he sits down and picks up the
mouse and makes his move
it will be all over everything's
forgotten and it's a new game okay and
here we go here we go some very quick
moves at the beginning ding nearly
always opens the game in this way he
always starts with his queen's pawn he
loves to put hit the white light squared
bishop on what we call a fiance on this
square actually on the longest possible
diagonal and magnus is kind of playing
copycat just erecting a very strong pawn
center there and uh now both sides will
just castle their kings over the next
couple of moves get those to safety and
again a battle for the center of the
board i've actually had this exact
position as black against ding myself
and magnus has experimented with this
type of opening with white lately but
also very experienced from the black
side and now completely symmetrical
position everything was balanced until
this point is still complete symmetry
it's copycat game and uh yeah right now
a big question for ding what to do next
how to stop magnus from copying his
moves it's the most frustrating thing in
chess when i first learned the game i
remember all of my opponents they would
just copy every single move i played and
somehow i didn't know how to punish them
and that is happening now it's quite
rare i must say but uh okay it's also
rare to see two dings two dings are
better than one but there we go
and actually the position is about to
repeat itself i hope we're not gonna see
a quick draw at this early stage magnus
now deciding whether to put his knight
in the center of the board or whether to
try a different strategy so right now
okay this is the second time we've seen
this position
ding last time brought the white knight
out the black knight retreated
okay will we see white retreat his night
the game's over guys anti-climax it's a
quick draw i'm surprised these two
playing a quick draw